THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CASA NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ACOSTA.
BAG WE ARE CURRY.
ALLEN.
MERRILEES.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BOROUGH.
BURKE.
GABRIELLE.
FULLER.
CDVA.
SO BONTA THIS.
CHAO.
CHAVEZ.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLEY.
DALY.
EGGMAN.
FLORA.
HONG.
FRAZIER.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAYSON.
HARPER.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KILEY.
LACKEY.
LEVINE.
WE KNOW.
LOW.
RAIMES.
MATHIS MAYES. MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN.
23-14.
WAS AREA AND.
MONNING.
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
RAY IS.
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO.
SOLACE
SANTIAGO OR.
STONE.
BERMAN.
TING.
VOEPEL.
WALDRON.
WEBER.
WORD.
MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
DAIS PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND BOB OSHITA
RIVER JUST.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
IT WAS ABOUT A DOZEN YEARS.
AGOTHAT A VERY YOUNG FRIEND OF
MINE NOW WILL ME FULL COLOR.
DISCOVERED THAT WE WERE BORN ON
THE SAME DAY MANY DECADES APART.
ON HER NINTH BIRTHDAY SHE MADE A
VERY SPECIAL BIRTHDAY CARD FOR
ME.
HER WORDS BROUGHT MEANING TO HER
COLORFUL DRAWING OF OUR SOLAR
SYSTEM.
SHE WROTE. CONGRATULATIONS
REVEREND BOB ON COMPLETING
ANOTHER TRIP AROUND THE SUN.
IT MADE GREAT SENSE FOR IT NINE
NOMI WANTED TO BE AN ASTRONAUT.
BUT HER CLEVER CREATIVE CARD.
MADE ME ALSO REALIZE THAT WE
RARELY GIVE THOUGHT TO THE FACT
THAT. EVERY SINGLE MOMENT WE ARE
CONSTANTLY IN MOTION.
OUR WORLD IS SPINNING AS OUR
EARTH IS CIRCLING THE SUN. IN
OUR SOLAR SYSTEM IS HURTLING
THROUGH SPACE WITHIN OUR GALAXY
THE MILKY WAY.
VERY IT LITERALLY ON EVERY LEVEL
OUR LIVES ARE IN CONSTANT
MOTION.
AND WE ARE ALL. CONSTANTLY
ADJUSTING TO CHANGES.
PHYSICALLY EMOTIONALLY SOCIALLY
POLITICALLY.
WE ARE CONSTANTLY HAVING TO
RESPOND AND REACT AND ADJUST TO
THE MANY CHANGES OF LIFE.
SOMETIMES THE CHANGES UNFOLD AS
WE HAD HOPED.
AND SOMETIMES NOT.
BUT AS LONG AS WE LIVE. THROUGH
ALL THE CHANGES LIFE BRINGS OUR
WAY. THAT HAS TRIED TO BE ON THE
PATH. OF BECOMING BETTER HUMAN
BEINGS.
WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE A BETTER
WORLD. AND A BETTER FUTURE
FOR THE GENERATIONS TO COME.
NO MORE NEED THEM.
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL. AS HE LEADS US
IN THE PLEDGE MISTER O'DONNELL.
KNOW YOUR HEART.
READY BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MARCH
SEVENTH TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE CEMENT AT SEVEN AM BEYOND
ROCKY CHAVEZ ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SERVICES.
CITING TO CLICK IT ALSO WASN'T
TO DEATH THREE HER THAT LIVE IN
THOSE READING
THE FOLLOWING REPLACE MY THE
MORNING ROLL CALL COSTS AND WE
ARE CURRY ARAMBULA BAKER BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BONTA BROUGH
BURKE.
CARILLO CALDERON ISRAEL'S WANT
US AROUND MOVES.
ND MISS WALDRON SECONDS HAVE
THE READING OF PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR.
THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY.
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MEDINA.
BIGELOW AND MELENDEZ.
FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS CHAO.
AND CHAVEZ AND FOR ILLNESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NEWS ARIANNE ON
PATERNITY LEAVE THIS AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
BRO
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
PROCEDURAL.
MOTIONS.
MISTER CALDERON. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION SIR. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
ONE EIGHTEEN A TO.
DOLLY
GALLAGHER GRAYSON MCCARTY MULLIN
AND
HELL TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS
FOR TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS DOLLY
GRAYSON AND VOEPEL GUESS WILL BE
SEATED AT THEIR DESKS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLINS GUEST WILL BE IN
THE AREA OF THE MEMBERS DOES.
FOR THE IRISH AMERICAN HERITAGE.
CEREMONY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FOUR POINT. FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TWO AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS KALRA EGGMAN
HOLDEN RODRIGUEZ GALLAGHER AND
GLORY TO SPEAK ON IT.
TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE TO RE REFER AB TWENTY NINE
THIRTY FOUR STONE FROM THE PART
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
GUESTS WITH US.
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
MISTER DALLI YOU HAVE A VIP ON
THE FLOOR WITH US YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THEY MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO. TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INTRODUCE TO YOU MY SON REAGAN
WHO.
THE LAST TIME WAS ON THIS FLOOR
I THINK WAS LIKE FIVE YEARS AGO.
IF YOU'LL STAND UP YOU CAN SEE
THAT HE'S GROWN UP A LITTLE BIT.
IT HE SAID THE ONE THAT
WRESTLES THAT I. I BRAG ABOUT
QUITE A BIT ON THE FLOOR HE'S
ALSO OUT RUNNING FOR THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE.
THE SUPERIOR REGION.
FFA SO THAT'S WHY YOU DON'T
HEAR HE'S BEEN CAMPAIGN A LITTLE
BIT. FOR FFA SO I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME AND INTRODUCE YOU TO HIM
ON THE FLOOR HERE
I GUESS
I CHAMBER TODAY I'M GOING TO
RECOGNIZE.
MISTER VOEPEL.
WHO HAS A SPECIAL GUEST WITH US
ON THE FLOOR MISTER VOEPEL YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED?
THIS IS SPEAKER.
HE LOVED IT MEMBERS.
MY WIFE SUSAN OF THIRTY FOUR
YEARS.
IS HERE
MEMBERS OF A HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION.
I BELIEVE.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ HAS GAS IN THE
GALLERY MISTER RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME WELCOMING
STUDENTS PARENTS AND TEACHERS.
FROM RIVERBEND CLASSICAL COME IN
CHINO CALIFORNIA THEY ARE. HERE
TODAY GETTING A CLOSE UP VIEW OF
THE STATE CAPITOL SO YOU'LL GIVE
A WARM WELCOME THERE TO MY LEFT
ABOVE US IN THE GALLERY. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US HERE TODAY
.
I'M GOING TO GO BACK TO MR
VOEPEL WHO HAS ADDITIONAL GAS
WITH US IN THE CHAMBER MISTER
PAL YOU.
I MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
JOIN US IN THE GALLERY TODAY OR
A FEW INFLUENTIAL COMMUNITY
LEADERS DISTINGUISH BUSINESS
OWNERS AND CLOSE FRIENDS OF MINE
FROM SAN T.. AND SUSAN'S A
MEMBER OF THE FRIDAY NIGHT
DINNER CLUB PLEASE GIVE THEM A
WARM APPLAUSE.
STAND UP GUYS
MEMBERS OF A HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION AND UP PLEASE GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION TO MISTER LEVINE
SPEAKING FROM THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S GAS FOR HIS GUESTS
INTRODUCTION THIS MOVIE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING THE MARIN
MONTESSORI SCHOOL FROM SANDRA
FELT WE GOT
THIRTY ONE STUDENTS IN FOR
FACULTY.
WHO ARE VISITING US AND A PLEASE
GIVE THEM A WARM WELCOME FOR THE
DAY IN SACRAMENTO THANK YOU
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE?
FILE ITEMS.
EIGHT THROUGH.
REMOVING THE SECOND READING THE
CLERK WILL READ SO THE CURRENT
SOLUTION ONE FIFTY WITH THE
MINNESOTA GO EIGHTEEN NINETY
FIVE MINUTES NINETEEN SIXTY ONE
OF THE MEMBERS EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN OR THE PARENTS NINETEEN OH
FORMER MINUTES ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN SIX.
AND ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THOUSAND
FOUR.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND THE MEANT THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
FILE ITEMS EIGHT THROUGH ELEVEN
WILL BE PASSED WILL BE
CONTINUED.
FILE ITEMS TWELVE AND THIRTEEN.
PASS AND RETAIN WE ARE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN HR EIGHTY TO
THE CLERK WILL PLEASE READ.
HOUSE WAS SOLUTION EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY RELATIVE
TO MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS AWARENESS
WEEK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY ARE
RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT HR EIGHTY TWO
RECOGNIZING MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS
AWARENESS WEEK AS WE KNOW EN
MASSE IS A DEBILITATING
NEUROLOGICAL DISEASE. AFFECTING
THE CENTRAL NERVOUS SYSTEM
MAKING REGULAR BODY FUNCTIONS
DIFFICULT.
THIS DISEASE AFFECTS FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE ACROSS
OUR NATION AND FORTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
MOST PEOPLE ARE DIAGNOSED
BETWEEN THE AGES OF TWENTY AND
FIFTY. AND THREE TIMES MORE
WOMEN THAN MEN ARE DIAGNOSED.
IT'S NINETEEN FORTY SIX THE
NATIONAL MS SOCIETY HAS WORKED
HARD TO FIND RESEARCH
SERVICE IS AND PROFESSIONAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
TO HELP THOSE AFFECTED WITH MS.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING HR
EIGHTY TWO RECOGNIZING MS
AWARENESS WEEK AND I ASKED THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
I THINK YOU SEEN NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION THE FIRST ROLE WILL
BE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS RULES FOR CO
ROLL IS FOR COAUTHORS MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE FIFTY NINE CO AUTHORS
ON THE MEASURE WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MR
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
SOMEONE MEMBER MCCARTY ARE
RECOGNIZED YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU I ALSO I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE MEMBERS OF THE
NATIONAL MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS
SOCIETY WHO ARE JOINING US WE
HAVE IF YOU. UP IN THE GALLERY.
AND A FEW IN THE BACK AS WELL WE
HAVE STUART FAIRY THE DIRECTOR
OF PUBLIC POLICY. WITH THE
NATIONAL MS SOCIETY AND MY GOOD
FRIEND ARE FORMER MAYOR OF
SACRAMENTO HEATHER FARGO THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
I THINK YOU'RE MOVING TO ITEM
FIFTEEN IT A BE EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
TWO OF MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
SO MY BRO EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER VOEPEL
ACRYLATE FIREARMS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER.
MEMBERS.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO IS OF
FOLLOW ON A ROUTINE FOLLOW ON
BILL.
FOR A. B. TWENTY ONE SIXTY FIVE
PASSED LAST YEAR WHAT IT
BASICALLY DOES IS IT ALLOWS LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACCESS TO CUTTING
EDGE. WEAPON TECHNOLOGY FOR
INSTANCE THE GLOCK FIVE THE
GLOCK SIX WHICH HAS TREMENDOUS
SAFETY FEATURES.
BUT.
THEY'RE NOT RECOGNIZED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS BEING A
SAFE WEAPON.
SO.
EIGHTEEN FIRST RESPONDERS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT ORGANIZATIONS
YOUR STREET COPS HIGHWAY PATROL
ON AND ON OR AUTHORIZED.
THESE WEAPONS BETTER DEEMED
UNSAFE FOR REGULAR CITIZENS.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
ADDS UP NINETEENTH CATEGORY.
WHICH IS HARBOR POLICE
THEY WERE INADVERTENTLY LEFT OFF
OF THE ORIGINAL BILL.
HARBOR POLICE WILL NOW BE ADDED
AND THEY CAN CARRY THE ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGY.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THE CLERK WILL PLEASE OPEN THE
RUN.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE A REAL ONE
TALLY THE VOTES.
FIFTY TWO. I.
KNOWN AS ZERO KNOWS.
THE BILL PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
GUESS INTRODUCTIONS.
WE ARE VOTE MISTER MULLIN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
REDUCTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
IT IS WITH GREAT PRIDE.
THAT I RISE TO WELCOME.
THE YOU NEVER OWE SARAH HIGH
SCHOOL BOYS VARSITY FOOTBALL
TEAM TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
THESE YOUNG MEN EXEMPLIFY WHAT
IT MEANS TO BE A STUDENT
ATHLETE.
AND THEY ARE THE WINNERS OF THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
INTERSCHOLASTIC FEDERATION STATE
DIVISION TO A A FOOTBALL
CHAMPIONSHIP.
BRINGING HOME THE FIRST STATE
CHAMPIONSHIP IN FOOTBALL IN THE
SCHOOL'S HISTORY.
IN A SEASON OF MANY FIRSTS SARAH
CHEAP THE MOST WINS IN A SEASON
WITH THIRTEEN. AND THE MOST W.
C. A. L. WINS FOR THE SEASON
WHICH HAD.
THE CULMINATION OF ITS BEST
SEASON CAME ON DECEMBER
FIFTEENTH TWENTY SEVENTEEN UNDER
THE TO OF HEAD COACH PATRICK
WALSH.
WHEN SARAH MARCHED WITH THIRTY
EIGHT TO FOURTEEN VICTORY OVER
CAJON HIGH SCHOOL. IN THE STATE
FINAL.
AS A PROUD SARAH LA IT IS MY
HONOR TO RECOGNIZE HIS TEAM AND
THE SCHOOL FOR ITS LONG TERM
SUCCESS. IN PREPARING STUDENTS.
WHO WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
THE LIVES OF OTHERS?
TEAM MEMBERS HAVE JOINED US ON
THE FLOOR TODAY AS WELL AS
COACHES.
AND OTHERS IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE WELCOME ATHLETIC DIRECTOR
DEAN A YOU.
HEAD COACH PATRICK WALSH.
AND PLAYERS ANDREAS ATKINS NIKO
RELIABLY NICHOLAS BRAUN A TONIO
MAFI AND MOVE BUT SORRY ONCE A
PADRE ALWAYS A PADRE PLEASE GIVE
THEM A HEARTY ROUND OF APPLAUSE
AS WE HONOR THEM ON THIS
ASSEMBLY FLOOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QADIR YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS UP PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING LEADERSHIP MORGANHILL
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY.
THEY ARE PARTICIPANTS IN AYE
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT AND
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT PROGRAM
AND ARE HERE TODAY TO EXPLORE
THAT THE
I CAPITAL SO GREAT TO SEE YOU
HERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
ITEM SIXTEEN PASS AND RETAIN.
SORRY CONTINUED.
MOVING TO ITEM SEVENTEEN ACR ONE
SIXTY FIVE MISTER CLERK PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SIXTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON RELATIVE
TO DOWN SYNDROME AWARENESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
GOOD MORNING MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT ACR ONE
SIXTY FIVE WHICH WILL PROCLAIM
THE WEEK OF MARCH EIGHTEENTH TO
MARCH TWENTY FOURTH TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. AS CALIFORNIA DOWN
SYNDROME AWARENESS WEEK
AND DESIGNATE MARCH TWENTY FIRST
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS
CALIFORNIA DOWN SYNDROME DAY.
AS THE MOST COMMONLY OCCURRING
CHROMOSOMAL CONDITION IN THE U.
S.
DOWN SYNDROME AFFECTS ABOUT ONE
OF EVERY SEVEN HUNDRED BIRTHS
NEARLY SIX THOUSAND BABIES EACH
YEAR.
DOWN SYNDROME OCCURS WHEN AN
INDIVIDUAL HAS A FULL OR PARTIAL
EXTRA COPY OF CHROMOSOME TWENTY
ONE.
THIS ADDITIONAL GENETIC MATERIAL
ALTERS THE COURSE OF DEVELOPMENT
AND CAUSES THE CHARACTERISTICS
ASSOCIATED WITH DOWN SYNDROME.
DOWN SYNDROME INCREASES THE RISK
FOR CERTAIN MEDICAL CONDITIONS
SUCH AS CONGENITAL HEART DISEASE
ARE DEFECTS RESPIRATORY AND
HEARING PROBLEMS. AND
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE
HOWEVER SINCE MANY OF THESE
CONDITIONS ARE TREATABLE THEY DO
NOT GREATLY DIMINISH THE QUALITY
OF LIFE OF INDIVIDUALS WITH DOWN
SYNDROME.
PEOPLE WITH DOWN SYNDROME ALSO
EXPERIENCE COGNITIVE DELAYS BUT
THE EFFECTS ARE USUALLY MILD TO
MODERATE AND ARE NOT INDICATIVE
OF THE MANY STRENGTHS AND
TALENTS THAT EACH INDIVIDUAL
POSSESSES. FOR INSTANCE MANY
INDIVIDUALS WITH DOWN SYNDROME
HAVE OVERCOME NUMEROUS OBSTACLES
TO ACHIEVE GREATNESS SUCH AS
FASHION DESIGNERS PUBLIC
SERVANTS AND ATHLETES INCLUDING
KIM CHANDLER WHO DESPITE MANY.
BEING UNABLE TO EXECUTE SIMPLE
MUSCLE MANEUVERS AS A CHILD
BECAME A FOUR TIME NATIONAL
CHAMPION AT THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS.
ACCESS TO QUALITY EDUCATION
PROGRAMS AND HEALTHCARE AND A
STIMULATING HOME ENVIRONMENT AND
A POSITIVE SUPPORT FROM FAMILY
FRIENDS AND COMMUNITY IN ABLE
THOSE WITH DOWN SYNDROME TO LEAD
FULFILLING AND PRODUCTIVE LIVES.
THIS PRODUCTIVITY INCLUDES BUT
IS NOT LIMITED TO ATTENDING
SCHOOL WORKING VOTING ADVOCATING
FOR THE WELL BEING OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND CONTRIBUTING TO
THE SOCIETY IN MANY MANY
WONDERFUL WAYS.
THIS RESOLUTION WILL BRING MUCH
NEEDED A PUBLIC AWARENESS TO
DOWN SYNDROME BY ENCOURAGING THE
ALLOCATION OF RESOURCES AND
ADVOCACY TO SUPPORT THE DOWN
SYNDROME COMMUNITY. I ASK HER
FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN TO CO
AUTHORS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND A GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF ACR ONE SIXTY FIVE.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FOR BRING THIS
RESOLUTION BEFORE US TODAY.
AS CHAIR OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES THIS
IS.
A TOPIC THAT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO ME.
ALL PEOPLE WITH DOWN SYNDROME OR
ANY CHALLENGE FOR THAT MATTER.
DESERVE OPPORTUNITIES TO
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR COMMUNITY AND
LIVE VALUED LIVES.
THESE INDIVIDUALS SHOULD BE
INCLUDED ON A FULL AND EQUAL
BASIS WITH OTHERS.
IN ALL ASPECTS OF SOCIETY.
WELL GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY
INDIVIDUALS WITH DOWN SYNDROME
CAN BRING SO MUCH TO OUR
COMMUNITY IN OUR WORKFORCE.
SO MANY ARE PREVENTED FROM
MAKING MEANINGFUL CONTRIBUTIONS
BECAUSE OF THIS PERCEIVED STIGMA
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE
CHALLENGES.
WE MUST SUPPORT THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR AND I ENCOURAGE EACH ONE
OF YOU COLLEAGUES.
TO HAVE AN INTERN WITH SOME KIND
OF CHALLENGE GOING FORWARD IN
THIS COMING YEAR.
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR SUPPORTING
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM CONCORD ON
THIS MUCH
NEEDED RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED HE.
YEAH JUST REAL QUICKLY I'D LIKE
TO THINK OF. MY COLLEAGUE FOR
CONCORD FOR BRINGING THIS KIND
OF RECOGNITION. THAT TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. I KNOW THAT.
WE HAVE MANY INDIVIDUALS TO.
HAVE THIS CONDITION THAT ARE SO
PRODUCTIVE WE HAVE TO.
MEMBERS OF THE.
OUR OUR APITAL FAMILY HERE
WHICH I KNOW WE HAVE JENNY AND
JOHN JENNY WORKS IN THE GIFT
SHOP AND HAS WORKED HERE FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS.
AND WE HAVE JOHN IN THE MAIL
DELIVERY OF SERVICE HERE IN THE
CAPITAL AND. THERE ARE
MEANINGFUL MEMBERS OF OUR OUR
CAPITAL FAMILY AND WE'RE VERY
VERY PROUD OF WHAT THEY DO AND
WE ALL NEED TO JUST RECOGNIZE
THE GREAT.
LIFE EXPERIENCE THAT THESE
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO ENJOY AND BE
PART OF.
WHAT THEY DESERVE IN AND A BRACE
WHAT THEY BRING TO OUR OUR
COMMUNITY AND TO OUR FAMILIES
AND SO? I WOULD ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS VERY WHERE THE
MEASURE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
ACR ONE SIX FIVE ELECT THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CONCORD. OF FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD.
AS MANY YOU KNOW I WORKED AT
THE REGIONAL CENTER FOR MANY
YEARS AND.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
LEARNED IN MY WORK AT THE
REGIONAL CENTER IS A SOCIAL
WORKER. IS THAT.
OUR COLLEAGUES ARE CITIZENS WHO
HAVE DOWN SYNDROME OFTEN
EXPERIENCE ISOLATION. ON AND AND
ALL THEY WANT IS WHAT WE ALL
WANT TO HAVE GOOD COLLEAGUES AND
FRIENDSHIPS.
AND TO FEEL SUPPORTED AND SO I
WOULD URGE US ALL HOW TO FOLLOW
ON THE SUGGESTION OF ARE CHAIR
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES. TO USE OUR OFFICES
ARE DISTRICT OFFICES TO REACH
OUT TO OUR LOCAL REGIONAL
CENTERS ARE DOZENS OF REGIONAL
CENTERS TO OUR STATE.
THAT CAN GIVE US OPPORTUNITIES
TO CONNECT EITHER TO HOST OF
SOMEONE AS AN INTERN.
OR TO HELP FACILITATE MATCHES
FROM CITIZENS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
WHO LIKE TO BE PARTNERS AND
FRIENDS VOLUNTEER DAY PROGRAMS
WHEN OTHER WAYS TO SUPPORT.
ARE GREAT CITIZENS AT A GREAT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AYE URGE AYE
VOTE ON ACR ONE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION THE PURPLE OPEN THE
ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS RULES FOR
COAUTHORS.
THIS RULE IS OPEN FOR CALL
AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MCCORKLE CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTES.
AND
TALLY THE. VOTES THERE ARE SIXTY
ONE COOPER IS ON THE MEASURE
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING
AYE.
AYE ALL OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MISTER
GRAYSON YOUR RECOGNIZED YOUR
GUESTS INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND DIE
I DO HAVE THE A GUEST IN TWO
DIFFERENT SPOTS UP IN THE
GALLERY I AM PLEASED TO WELCOME
SEVERAL ORGANIZATIONS DEDICATED
TO SERVING INDIVIDUALS WITH DOWN
SYNDROME. TO THE ASSEMBLY
GALLERY AND INCLUDING THEY
INCLUDE DOWN SYNDROME CONNECTION
OF THE BAY AREA DOWN SYNDROME
ASSOCIATION NORTH BAY.
CALIFORNIA DOWN SYNDROME
ADVOCACY COALITION AND DOWN
SYNDROME.
INFORMATION ALLIANCE THESE
ORGANIZATIONS WORK TIRELESSLY TO
ENSURE THE INDIVIDUALS WITH DOWN
SYNDROME. AS WELL AS OUR
FAMILIES HAVE RESOURCES SUPPORT
COMMUNITY.
THAT THEY NEED FOR HEALTH
HEALTHY LIVING LIVES AND I AM
INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR THEIR
WORK IN ADVERSITY IN THE BACK I
HAVE SOME VERY VERY SPECIAL
GUEST.
I HAVE WITH THIS ELI AND
JENNIFER COOPER FROM BERKELEY
LARISSA ERICA ERICKSON FROM
ALAMEDA NANCY LA BELLE WHO
REPRESENTS DOUBTS OF DRUG
CONNECTION BAY AREA.
BLUES FROM DANVILLE AND AND
TOBY LYNN FROM PULL SOME I HAVE
MY LOVELY WIFE WITH ME ASSURE
THIS WAIVER HANDS. AND THEN I
HAVE AN EXTRAORDINARY
SPECIAL SPECIAL GUEST WITH ME
TODAY. I FLOOR ALL THE WAY OUT
HERE FROM THE MIDWEST TO BE WITH
ME TODAY TO CELEBRATE THIS AND
YOUR SUPPORT FOR DOWN SYNDROME.
YEAH I AND.
THIS A LITTLE STORY ABOUT HER
MY WIFE AND I WERE TAKING YOUR
SHOPPING ONE DAY WE WERE WALKING
THROUGH THE SUCH A QUARTER OF A
MALL. FOR YOUNG ADULTS WERE
APPROACHING US.
AND YOU COULD SEE THAT.
.
THEY WERE.
STARING IN A IN A VERY BLATANT
WAY MY WIFE AND I WERE SEEKING
CERTAIN THINGS WONDERING WHAT
SHE WAS THINKING.
BRUCE IS WHAT THE DOWN SYNDROME
COMMUNITY IS ALL ABOUT THAT
EXTRA CHROMOSOME THEY HAVE IT'S
AN EXTRA CHROMOSOME OF LOVE.
BECAUSE WHEN THEY PASSED
SHERRY LOOKED UP AT MY WIFE AND
I AND ALL SHE SAID WAS I THINK
THEY LIKE MY DRESS.
AND.
SHERRY DENISE GRAYSON WELCOME
TO CALIFORNIA AND WELCOME TO THE
CAPITAL PLEASE WELCOME MY
SPECIAL GUEST TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MOVING TO ITEM
EIGHTEEN ACR ONE NINETY THREE
MISTER QUICKLY THREE. SO WE CAN
CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE NINETY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER BAKER
RELATIVE TO GIRL SCOUTS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAKER YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
TO YOU TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS ACR
ONE NINETY THREE. TO CELEBRATE
THE ONE HUNDRED SIXTH
ANNIVERSARY OF GIRL SCOUTS OF
AMERICA. BACK IN NINETEEN TWELVE
THE FIRST GIRL SCOUT MEETING WAS
HELD IN SAVANNAH GEORGIA AND WAS
LED BY JULIETTE GORDON LOW WHO
FOUNDED THE GIRL SCOUTS OF
AMERICA. THEIR OBJECTIVE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN TO BUILD GIRLS OF
COURAGE CONFIDENCE AND CHARACTER
WHO MAKE A BETTER WORLD FOR
EVERYONE
AND THEY DO THAT BY CREATING A.
WONDERFUL SISTERHOOD OF
COURAGEOUS AND CONFIDENT WOMEN
THROUGHOUT THE NATION AND THE
WORLD.
GIRLS THROUGH THE GIRL SCOUTS OF
AMERICA LEARNED THAT THERE IS NO
LIMIT TO THEIR SUCCESS OR WHAT
THEY CAN ACCOMPLISH. AND I THINK
MANY OF US HAVE EXPERIENCED THAT
CERTAINLY IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS
IF YOU'VE BEEN EATING ANY GIRL
SCOUT COOKIES. WEED FORMER TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE GIRL
SCOUT COOKIES IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER JUST HOW EXTENSIVE AND
BROUGHT THEIR INVOLVEMENT IN OUR
COUNTRY HAS BEEN. SINCE THAT
FIRST MEETING IN SAVANNAH
GEORGIA MORE THAN FIFTY NINE
MILLION GIRLS HAVE PARTICIPATED
IN THE GIRL SCOUT MOVEMENT
DURING THEIR CHILDHOOD. AND THAT
NUMBER CONTINUES TO GROW AS THE
GIRL SCOUT OF THE MET AMERICA
CONTINUES TO INSPIRE AND INVITE
NEW MEMBERS. THERE ARE CURRENTLY
TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION GIRL
SCOUTS ONE POINT NINE GIRL
MEMBERS AND EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND ADULT MEMBERS WHO.
ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY WORK AS
VOLUNTEERS AT CAMPS THROUGH
THEIR GIRL SCOUT TROOPS ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. THROUGH
MEMBERSHIP IN THE WORLD
ASSOCIATION OF GIRL SCOUT GUIDES
WHICH I ENCOURAGE YOU TO FIND
OUT MORE ABOUT AND GIRL SCOUTS
OF AMERICA IS PART OF A
WORLDWIDE FAMILY OF TEN MILLION
GIRLS AND WOMEN IN THE HUNDRED
AND FORTY SIX COUNTRIES.
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
WOMEN CURRENTLY IN THE UNITED
STATES SENATE
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT.
AND MORE THAN HALF OF THE EIGHTY
EIGHT WOMEN IN THE UNITED STATES
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES WERE
GIRL SCOUTS WHEN THEY WERE
CHILDREN. FIFTY FIVE PERCENT OF
ALL WOMEN ASTRONAUTS ARE FORMER
GIRL SCOUTS.
AND GIRL SCOUTS HAVE FLOWN IN
OVER ONE THIRD OF ALL SPACE
SHUTTLE MISSIONS.
AND AN ESTIMATED EIGHTY PERCENT
OF WOMEN WHO ARE BUSINESS
EXECUTIVES AND BUSINESS OWNERS
IN AMERICA WERE GIRL SCOUTS.
I GOT ONE MORE STATISTIC FLOREA
SIXTY FOUR PERCENT OF TODAY'S
FEMALE LEADERS WHO ARE LISTED IN
THE WHO'S WHO OF AMERICAN WOMEN
IN THE UNITED STATES WERE ONCE
GIRL SCOUTS.
AS AN ARCHERY INSTRUCTOR A GIRL
SCOUT CAMP A DIABLO DAY CAMP IN
THE SAN RAMON VALLEY AREA OF
THIS IS A DAY CAMP THE GOES
THROUGHOUT THE SUMMER. AND YOU
CAN SEE THE GIRLS OF ALL AGES
WORKING TOGETHER THEIR SCHOOL
LEADERS WHO ARE IN CHARGE OF THE
ORGANIZATION'S ACTIVITIES FOR
THE DAY THE GIRLS DO THE
PLANNING THEY DO THE EXECUTION.
AND THEY MAKE A GREAT EXPERIENCE
FOR GIRLS ALL ACROSS THE
COMMUNITY AND.
I PARTICULARLY LOVE TO BE ON
THE RANGE WHERE THEY THEY START
THE WEEK OFF.
KIND OF EXCITED ABOUT THE
ACTIVITY AND FRUSTRATED THAT
THEY CAN'T QUITE GET A A TARGET
IN THE BULLS EYE BUT BY THE END
OF THE WEEK WITH PERSISTENCE IN
WORK YOU SEE THEIR CONFIDENCE
BUILD. AND THEY HIT THE POLLS I
ON THE TARGET IN ARCHERY AND
THEY LOVE IT THAT'S ONE OF THE
WONDERFUL THINGS ABOUT GIRL
SCOUTS OF AMERICA. ENDS.
IF YOU HAVE HAD SOME OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES SHARE WITH YOU SOME
GIRL SCOUT COOKIES.
THOSE FIRST CAME TO BE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTEEN AND THEY WERE
BATES AND HOME OVENS BY
INDIVIDUAL GIRL SCOUT FAMILIES
IT WAS UNTIL THE FIFTIES THEY
REALLY STARTED TO HAVE THE THIN
MINTS IN THE SANDWICH COOKIES.
AND OTHER SHORT BREATHS IT HELPS
BUILD ENTREPRENEURSHIP SKILLS
BUSINESS SKILLS LEADERSHIPAND
COMMUNICATION SKILLS FOR GIRL
SCOUTS AND PARTICULARLY A SHOUT
OUT TO TWO MORE GROUPS AND THAT
IS THE MOMS AND THE PARENTS.
WHO LEAD GIRL SCOUT TROOPS THESE
ARE OTHER ADULTS WHO WERE
HELPING OTHER PEOPLE'S CHILDREN
BECOME BETTER CITIZENS AND
BETTER MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
AND THEY DO THAT? WITHOUT A LOT
OF EXTRA TIME ON THEIR HANDS AND
A SPECIAL SHOUT OUT TO THE
PARENTS WHO DID NOT SELL THE
COOKIES FOR THEIR DAUGHTERS. BUT
ALLOW THEIR DAUGHTERS TO COME
AND ASK US AND LEARN HOW TO
BUILD CLIENTS AND RUN A
BUSINESS.
I LOOK AT YOU THE MEMBER FROM
SACRAMENTO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DOCTORS YOUR TWIN DAUGHTERS
COMING AND VISITING MY OFFICE IN
ASKING THEMSELVES IF I WOULD BUY
COOKIES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE IN THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING GIRL SCOUTS OF
AMERICA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU I RISE ON BEHALF OF
THE GIRL SCOUT DAD CAUCUS.
FEW OF US IN HERE AND THAT YOU
KNOW THIS IS REALLY AYE AYE
SPOUSAL ORGANIZATION AND I NEED
TO SAY THAT. I'LL GET TO THE
COOKIES IN A SECOND BUT OF
COURSE A LOT OF LIFE LESSONS
LEARNED ABOUT.
LEADERSHIP AND CONSCIOUSNESS
AND.
AND CULTURE AWARENESS
UNDERSTANDING AND TOLERANCE BUT
ALSO SOMETIMES THERE'S LIFE
LESSONS ON THE OTHER SIDE AS
WELL GIVE AN EXAMPLE YOU MAY SAW
RIPPED FROM THE HEADLINES HERE A
MONTH AGO. OUR GIRL SCOUT TROOP
WAS SELLING GIRL SCOUTS HAD A
SAFE WAY AND SOMEBODY CAME UP
AND GIMMICK COUNTERFEIT ONE
HUNDRED DOLLAR BILL. HE WOULD DO
THAT. THEY GOT TWO BOXES OF
COOKIES AND THEY GOT NINETY
DOLLARS BACK AND SO THE GIRLS
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED AND
HAPPEN WHO WOULD DO SUCH A
THING.
BUT YOU KNOW SOMETIMES THESE
LEADERSHIP.
COURSES I TEACH ABOUT.
HOW HOW YOU GET UP FROM THESE
ROUGH TIMES AND HOW YOU BOUNCE
BACK AND SO THAT'S WHAT'S SO
IMPORTANT ABOUT THESE LEADERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE THE GIRLS
SAT AMONGST EACH OTHER TALKED
ABOUT IT? AND HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO FOCUS ON A REAL WORLD LIFE
EXPERIENCE BUT I DO WONDER I
RECOGNIZE.
THE SECOND FLOOR UP THERE OF A
STATE CAPITOL.
BECAUSE WE ARE GIRLS SOLD FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY BOXES OF GIRL
SCOUT COOKIES THIS YEAR AND WE
SPECIAL ONE A SHOT OUT TO THE
SECOND FLOOR UP THERE FOR. FOR
MAKING SURE THEY ON THEY THEY
HELPED OUT AND I'M SURE THERE ON
A GREAT BIG SUGAR HIGH THIS WEEK
SO I THINK YOU SO MUCH AND
CERTAINLY OUR RIGHTS IN SUPPORT
OF ACR ONE NINETY THREE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
ACR ONE NINETY THREE.
I THINK MY COLLEAGUE FOR SENATE
KNOWN FOR BRINGING IT FOR.
AND I'M A PROUD MEMBER OF THE
GIRL SCOUT PARA CAUCUS WELL. I'M
THANK YOU TO THOSE OF YOU WHO
SUPPORTED UP MY DAUGHTER'S.
WHO HAD BEEN ACTIVE IN AND GIRL
SCOUTS FOR MOST OF THEIR LIFE?
ATTENDING CAMPS I'M SELLING
COOKIES PARTICIPATING IN
ACTIVITIES ALMOST EVERY OTHER
WEEKEND.
I TOO WOULD GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO
THE PARENTS INTO A VOLUNTEER
TROOP LEADERS WHO SPENT SO MUCH
TIME. ORGANIZING ACTIVITIES AND
WALLACE SEEMS INFORMAL IT REALLY
IS FOCUS ON LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT.
AND AND BUILDING.
YOU KNOW COLLEAGUES TO WORK
TOGETHER ON PROJECTS I WOULD
JUST ECHO ALL THE THINGS THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN RAMON SAID.
ABOUT THE GREAT.
OUT COMES UP FOR THE GIRL
SCOUTS IN THEIR HUNDRED SIX YEAR
HISTORY THAT THE NUMBER OF
FEMALE LEADERS C. E. O.'S
SENATORS AND ASTRONAUTS WHO
WOULD NOT WANT TO SUPPORT AN
ORGANIZATION.
THAT ALLOWS OUR YOUNG WOMEN OF
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DREAM AND
GAIN EXPERIENCE BE TO BECOME
TOMORROW'S ENTREPRENEURS ARE
TOMORROW'S LEADERS UP FOR THOSE
OF YOU. WHO ARE INTERESTED? IN
SUPPORTING THE GIRL SCOUTS SOME
OF US STILL HAVE COOKIES LEFT
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR
NEED.
I DO WANNA SHARE ONE THING THAT
I LEARNED RECENTLY ABOUT THE
GIRL SCOUTS
AND THAT IN ADDITION TO ALL THE
THINGS THEY DO AROUND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP. THEY MAKE STEM
A SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING
AND MATH ONE OF THEIR TOP
PRIORITIES ANY OFFER A NUMBER OF
STEM BADGES OUGHT TO SUPPORT.
THE GIRL SCOUTS INCLUDING A
DIGITAL ARTS BATCH TO HELP BUILD
TECHNOLOGY AND COMPUTER SKILLS
AND A SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY
BADGE TO CONNECT GIRLS TO FUN
SCIENCE TOPICS. SUCH AS ROLLER
COASTER PHYSICS IN VIDEO GAME
DEVELOPMENT THIS AMAZING
TREASURE THAT WE HAVE HAD. FOR
THE LAST ONE HUNDRED AND SIX
YEARS A ONE WISH A HAPPY
ANNIVERSARY TO THE GIRL SCOUTS.
OF THE USA AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT
OF ACR ONE NINETY THREE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAKER
WOULD YOU LIKE THE FIRST ROLE TO
BE FOR CO AUTHORS I WOULD PLEASE
JUST A BRIEF MOMENT TO CLOSE AND
I THINK OUR COLLEAGUES FOR.
FOR THEIR COMMENTS AND ALSO I'M
I'M SURE NONE OF THEM ARE TRYING
TO SELL COOKIES PASSED THE
DEADLINE.
WHICH RECENTLY EXPIRED BUT MAKE
SURE THAT YOU YOU SUPPORT GIRLS
WHO COME UP AND KNOCK ON YOUR
DOOR OR SELL THOSE COOKIES.
AND ALSO THE GIRL SCOUT GOLD
AWARD MANY OF US ARE INVITED TO
EAGLE COURTS OF HONOR.
AND CELEBRATE OUR BOY SCOUTS
AND WHEN THEY REACH THAT
REMEMBER THAT THE BRONZE SILVER
AND ULTIMATELY GOAL TOWARD WITH
GIRL SCOUTS IS EQUALLY
CHALLENGING PROJECT FOR THEM TO
DO IN THAT AND BE SURE TO GIVE
THAT EQUAL TIME IN ENCOURAGEMENT
AND PRAISE. WHEN GIRL SCOUTS ARE
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND AND REACHED
OUT AND ALL THEIR OTHER GOALS
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND CO AUTHORS THINKING.
THANK YOU MISTER CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE FOR AUTHORS.
MEMBERS.
THIS ROLE IS FOR COAUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR COAL AUTHORS ON
THE GIRL SCOUT RESOLUTION.
MISTER CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY TWO
COAUTHORS WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
PLEASE SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL OPPOSED THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED
ITEMS NINETEEN THROUGH TWENTY
ONE WILL BE PASS AND RETAIN
ITEMS TWENTY THREE TO TWENTY
FIVE PASS AND RETAIN MOVING BACK
NOW. TO ITEM TWENTY TWO ACR ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHILE THE OTHERS
RELATIVES IRISH AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS ACR ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT DESIGNATES MARCH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AS IRISH AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH.
IN HONOR OF THE MULTITUDE OF
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT IRISH
AMERICANS HAVE MADE TO THE
COUNTRY AND STATE.
MILLIONS OF IRISH PEOPLE FACE
WAS SEVERE HARDSHIP DUE TO
FAMINE AND POVERTY IN THEIR
NATION. IMMIGRATED TO THE UNITED
STATES OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
CENTURIES IN SEARCH OF A MORE
PROMISING FUTURE FOR THEMSELVES.
AND THEIR FAMILIES
THE JOURNEY TO AMERICA WAS NOT
PAVED WITH GOLD LIKE MANY
IMMIGRANTS THE AVERAGE SPIRIT OF
DETERMINATION. PERSEVERANCE AND
GRIT PREVAILED AGAINST DANGEROUS
SEAS AND DEADLY CONDITIONS WITH
THEIR HEARTS SET ON THE HORIZON.
IRISH AMERICANS INITIALLY
SUFFERED PREJUDICE AND
DISCRIMINATION UPON FIRST
ARRIVING IN THE U. S..
AS THE YEARS WENT ON IRISH
AMERICANS BECAME DEEPLY
INTEGRATED IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND MADE NUMEROUS CONTRIBUTIONS
IN ALL ASPECTS OF AMERICAN
SOCIETY. AND CULTURE.
IRISH AMERICANS HAVE PLAYED
VITAL ROLES IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE UNITED STATES NINE IRISH
AMERICANS WERE SIGNERS OF THE
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE.
TWENTY TWO PRESIDENTS OF THE
UNITED STATES HAVE BEEN OF IRISH
HERITAGE.
INCLUDING JOHN F. KENNEDY RONALD
REAGAN BILL CLINTON AND BARACK
OBAMA.
MANY PEOPLE OF IRISH DESCENT
HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO GREAT MOOMIN
SET OF HELPED SHAPE OUR COUNTRY
AND ITS ROLE IN THE WORLD
INCLUDING MOTHER JONES LABOR
ACTIVISTS.
LUCY BURNS ACTIVISTS IN THE
WOMEN'S MOVEMENT. AND SENATOR
GEORGE MITCHELL NEGOTIATOR OF
THE IRISH PEACE ACCORD.
IRISH AMERICANS HAVE ALSO PLAYED
A MAJOR ROLE IN CALIFORNIA
POLITICS IS GOVERNOR'S
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS CITY MAYORS
AND OTHER PUBLIC OFFICIALS WHO
HAVE WORKED TIRELESSLY TO BUILD
THE CALIFORNIA. WE KNOW TODAY.
IN FACT GOVERNOR BROWN WAS JUST
INDUCTED IN THE IRISH AMERICAN
HALL OF FAME IN NEW YORK EARLIER
THIS MONTH FOR THE YEARS OF
SERVICE HE HAS DEDICATED. TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
TODAY OVER THIRTY FOUR MILLION
AMERICANS CLAIM IRISH HERITAGE
AND THEY CONTINUE TO CONTRIBUTE
TO AMERICAN AND CALIFORNIA
POLITICS
ECONOMY. AND CULTURE I ASK FOR
CO AUTHORS AND I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION THE CLERK
WILL PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE FOR CO
AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS WILL CALL
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE SIXTY FIVE CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THIS ITEM ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MR MON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I HAVE A
NUMBER OF GUESTS WITH US IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY I'M GOING TO START
RIGHT HERE AT MY DESK YOU MAY
HAVE NOTICED THE TWO LITTLE
IRISH BLESSINGS. PARKED NEXT TO
MY DESK ON THE FLOOR THE
ASSEMBLY. MEMBERS PLEASE WELCOME
MY WIFE JESSICA ALONG WITH OUR
TWIN SONS LIAM GENE AND LANDED
ROBERT MULLIN HAVE JOINED US ON
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR TODAY.
MISTER DOWLING NOW MEMBERS I
HAVE ADDITIONAL DIGNITARIES.
WITH US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
IT IS MY PLEASURE. TO INTRODUCE
SPECIAL GAS.
THAT HAVE JOINED US FOR IRISH
HERITAGE DAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MISTER
ROBERT O'DRISCOLL. AND MS
HEATHER HUMPHREYS.
MR DRISKELL WAS APPOINTED
IRELAND'S CONSUL GENERAL TO THE
WESTERN UNITED STATES IN JULY OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
HE PREVIOUSLY SERVED OVERSEAS
AS CONSULATE IRELAND'S EMBASSY
TO THE KINGDOM OF SAUDI ARABIA.
AS DEPUTY HEAD OF MISSION IN
IRELAND'S EMBASSY TO UNITED ARAB
EMIRATES AND IN IRELAND'S
PERMANENT MISSION TO THE
EUROPEAN
UNION. IN IRELAND HE SERVED AS
PRIVATE SECRETARY TO IRELAND'S
DEPUTY PRIME MINISTER AND ALSO
IRELAND'S MINISTER FOR FOREIGN
AFFAIRS.
BEFORE TAKING UP HIS CURRENT
POSITION ROBERT WAS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR IN THE TRADE DIVISION
IN THE IRISH DEPARTMENT. OF
FOREIGN AFFAIRS.
IT'S HUMPHREY'S IS THE IRISH
GOVERNMENT MINISTER. WITH
RESPONSIBILITY FOR BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE AND INNOVATION ITS
OVERSEAS IRELAND'S TRADE AND
INVESTMENT LINKS WITH THE WORLD
INCLUDING THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ONE OF IRELAND'S MOST
IMPORTANT ECONOMIC PARTNERS.
SHE HAS PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS THE
MINISTER WITH RESPONSIBILITY FOR
RURAL AFFAIRS AND ALSO FOR
PROMOTING IRISH CULTURE. THE
ARTS AND THE GAELIC SPEAKING
AREAS OF IRELAND.
IN THE LATTER ROLE SHE
SUCCESSFULLY OVERSAW THE IRISH
GOVERNMENT CENTENNIAL
CELEBRATIONS OF THE NINETEEN
SIXTEEN RISING IN IRELAND. SHE
HAS REPRESENTED THE PEOPLE OF.
COMBINE BUT NOT BUT I'M.
IN IRELAND SIX TWENTY ELEVEN.
ALSO JOINING US TODAY IN THE
GALLERY ARE DOCTOR OR LIKE
QUINN.
PERMEATE OR THE QUEEN IS ON THE
FLOOR WITH THAT SHE IS THE
SECRETARY GENERAL. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE INNOVATION LUCY
MOYLAN PRESS ADVISER. AMY
MCCORMICK PRIVATE SECRETARY
PARENTS A ROCK CHAIRMAN OF
ENTERPRISE IRELAND AND PAUL BURR
FIELD SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT FOR
NORTH AMERICA ENTERPRISE IRELAND
LET'S GIVE THEM ALL A WARM
ASSEMBLY WELCOME
MEMBERS TRADITIONAL IRISH DO ART
OF IRISH CULTURE DATING TO
FIVE HUNDRED BC.
THE KENNELLY SCHOOL OF IRISH
DANCE HOLDS MANY TITLES AND HAS
BEEN PERFORMING LOCALLY FOR TWO
DECADES.
THEY PERFORMED HERE IN THE
ASSEBLY FOR MANY OF OUR IRISH
AMERICAN HERITAGE CELEBRATIONS
IN THE PAST.
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO WE HAVE A
VERY SPECIAL TREAT AND LET'S
WELCOME THAT CAN ONLY SCHOOL OF
IRISH DANCE
.
THE
THIS
NNOVA
THAT WAS AN EXCELLENT
PERFORMANCE.
AS A SOUVENIR PER OBSERVANCE OF
IRISH AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH
MEMENTOS HAVE BEEN DELIVERED TO
YOUR OFFICES
PLACE UNDER DESKS.
THE SHAMROCK PLAN REPRESENTS THE
NUMBER THREE EVERYTHING GOOD IN
IRELAND COMES IN THREES.
AND THE GOURMET SOURED JELLY
BEANS ON YOUR DESK OR FROM A
COMPANY IN MISTER MULLINS
HOMETOWN IN SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO.
ON BEHALF OF MR MULLIN MISTER
BRO IN THE THIRTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OF IRISH HERITAGE I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE DANCERS
AND THE IRISH DELEGATION FOR
THEIR PARTICIPATION TODAY. THIS
CONCLUDES OUR CEREMONY.
WE ARE MOVING IN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH
TO REMOVE AND I'LL ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND THEY
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SO WE GROW EIGHTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SOLACE
INOCULATE THE POLICE OFFICERS.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE COUNTER.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROWING
TALLY THE VOTES THEIR SIXTY EYES
NOSE ZERO.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY READ.
SO WE GO NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR.
I SIXTEEN KNOWS NON CONSUMABLE
NINETEEN FORTY ONE. EYES SIXTY
KNOWS NONE AND ASSUME AGO
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE I SIXTY
KNOWS NINE.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR MISTER SPEAKER
STEPS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
IN LIGHT OF IT BEING OF AG DAY
BEING UPON US I THOUGHT IT
APPROPRIATE THAT WE CELEBRATE.
AND AG TEACHER.
THE FAMOUS PAUL HARVEY SEGMENT.
SAID GOD NEEDED A CARETAKER.
SO HE MADE SO GOD MADE A FARMER.
WELL GOD NEEDED FARMERS.
SO HE MADE LAURIE GOT US.
YOU KNOW I KNOW WE ALL IN THIS
ROOM HAVE TEACHERS WHO. IMPACTED
OUR LIVES LAURIE GOSS WAS THAT
FOR ME.
FOR TWENTY EIGHT YEARS LAURIE
GOSS GAVE HER ALL. AS AN AG
TEACHER AND FFA ADVISOR HE'S
NICHOLAS HIGH SCHOOL.
HER WORK WAS RIGHT RECOGNIZE
STATEWIDE BY THE FUTURE FARMERS
OF AMERICA.
AND THE CALIFORNIA ACT TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE HAVE.
IN THE GALLERY SOME OF THE AG
TEACHERS.
WITH US TODAY.
TO COMMEMORATE THIS.
LAST YEAR WE LOST THIS BEAUTIFUL
SOUL.
MY AG TEACHER R. AG TEACHER.
AND TODAY WE REMEMBER HER GREAT
CONTRIBUTIONS.
SHE WAS TRULY AMAZING RELENTLESS
REALLY.
I NEVER SAW OUR STOP WEATHER WAS
TEACHING.
DRIVING KIDS TO EVENTS VISITING
HER STUDENTS TO SEE OTHER ANIMAL
PROJECTS WERE GOING.
VOLUNTEERING WITH THE KIDS AT
AN EVENT.
SHE NEVER STOPPED IN HER HUSBAND
GEORGE I KNOW CONTRIBUTE.
CAN ATTEST TO THAT.
IN FACT I DON'T THINK SHE EVER
SLEPT.
THAT FAIR SHE WAS EVERYWHERE AND
I MEAN EVERYWHERE.
WE COULD GET AWAY WITH ANYTHING
IN BELIEVE ME WE TRY.
A.
NOT THOSE SAME FAIRGROUNDS THEY
WERE PACKED.
THAT HER MEMORIAL SERVICE BY
THOSE WHO HAD BEEN IMPACTED. BY
HER.
SHE WOULD ENCOURAGE US
CHALLENGES AND ALSO KICK* IN
THE REAR WHEN WE NEEDED IT.
SHE WOULD ADVISING GUIDE BUT SHE
WOULD NEVER CAUGHT.
RATHER SHE WOULD LEAD U. UP TO
THE EDGE AND THEN DROP YOUR IN
THE DEEP END OF THE POOL AND SAY
STARTS WHEN.
SHE PURPOSELY PUT US IN GROUPS
AROUND PEOPLE WHO CHALLENGE US
AND PUSH US AND SHARPEN OUR
SKILLS.
SHE WAS MAMA GOTS TO US.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY TO HER
CHILDREN HEIDI CODY AND MADDIE
WERE WITH.
ME HERE ON THE FLOOR.
WERE ALWAYS TAGGING ALONG ON
SOME ADVENTURE.
HER EYES WOULD BEAM WHEN YOU
ASKED ABOUT HER CHILDREN.
EVEN PREGNANT WITH MADDY MY
SENIOR YEAR YOU COULDN'T KEEP
GOSS FROM BEING DAS.
YOU KEPT AFTER STUDENTS EVEN
FACING A RABIES SCARE WHEN SHE
CARED FOR A PIG ATTACK BY
COYOTES.
YOU JUST COULD NOT SLOWER A LOT
YOU COULD NOT SLOWER DOWN LET
ALONE STOP.
BUT GOD HAD A GREATER THING IN
MIND.
DRIVING US TO CONVERT HIS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE SHOWING US HOW TO
JUDGE BEEF AND SHEAR SHEEP.
SHE WAS DEDICATED TO A MISSION.
TO PROMOTE AGRICULTURE THE
INDUSTRY AND THE WAY OF LIFE.
TO SEE T. AND THE PASSING ON OF
VITAL SKILLS AND KNOWLEDGE TO
THE NEXT GENERATION.
BUT MORE IMPORTANT AND THAT. TO
INSPIRE US TO BE LEADERS.
WHO WOULD THEN BECOME ADVOCATES
OURSELVES?
AS THE FFA CREED STATES.
SHE BELIEVED IN THE FUTURE OF
AGRICULTURE WITH THE FAITH BORN
NOT OF WORDS. BUT A DEEDS.
OUR MOTTO IS LEARN BY DOING. AND
SHE DID A LOT OF DOING.
SHE WAS WEAVING A TAPESTRY.
A NETWORK OF SUCCESS.
SHE WANTED YOU TO SUCCEED MEN
SHE WAS THE MOST SELFLESS PERSON
WHEN IT CAME TO OUR STUDENTS.
SHE ALWAYS PUT HER STUDENTS
BEFORE SELF.
AND SHE WAS BELOVED BY THOSE
STUDENTS TODAY WE HAVE SOME OF
THOSE STUDENTS WITH US.
UP IN THE GALLERY AND ASK YOU TO
STAND IF YOU WERE ONE OF LAURIE
GOSS'S.
STUDENTS.
BUT IT WASN'T JUST ABOUT YOUR
SUCCESS SHE HAD IN MIND HOW THAT
SUCCESS MIGHT READ OTHER
PEOPLE'S SUCCESS.
EVEN AFTER WE GRADUATED WE WOULD
OCCASIONALLY GET THE CALL FROM
COST TO HELP.
JUDGE A CONTEST OR SPEAK TO SOME
STUDENTS.
AND YOU WOULD NOT WOULD NOT SAY
NO TO MAMA GUYS.
UNDER LAST DAY ON THIS EARTH SHE
CONVENE A MEETING AT THE SCHOOL
WITH PARENTS SUPPORTERS AND
FORMER STUDENTS TALKING ABOUT
THE NEED. TO INVEST IN AG
EDUCATION.
THAT'S HOW SHE SPENT HER LAST
DAY.
AND TODAY HER TREMENDOUS LEGACY
LIVES ON. IN HER CHILDREN WERE
WITH ME.
HERE IN THE STUDENTS THAT YOU
SEE UP IN THE GALLERY AND IN THE
AG PROGRAM THAT SHE HELPED
BUILD.
WE ARE ALL GOT STRONG BECAUSE OF
HER.
TODAY IS MY HONOR TO PRESENT
THIS RESOLUTION.
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY.
AT HER AMAZING FAMILY HER
HUSBAND GEORGE.
AND CHILDREN CODY HEIDI AND
MADDIE.
WE LOVE YOU ALL AND THANK YOU
FOR LETTING NOT LETTING HER BE
OUR MODEL GUS
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS AND ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A JOURNEY MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE EXIT THE CHAMBERS
OR TAKE YOUR SEATS FOR THE
GERMAN THE MEMORIES
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO ASK THAT WE HAD DURING
THE ASSEMBLY IN THE MEMORY OF
GRAD WORK AT.
A PROUD FATHER A LOVING HUSBAND.
A VETERAN AND A DEDICATED MEMBER
OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY
IN SAN DIEGO WHO PASSED AWAY ON
MARCH SIXTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AT
JUST FIFTY YEARS OLD.
BRETT WAS THE SECOND CHILD OF
JIM AND BONNIE BRIQUETTE.
HE GREW UP IN TRENTON TENNESSEE
ALONG WITH HIS BROTHER JASON AND
HIS YOUNGER SISTER BETSY.
RIGHT MOVE TO CALIFORNIA RIGHT
BEFORE ENTERING THE EIGHTH GRADE
ME QUICKLY EMBRACED THE SUN AND
SAND AND SURF OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AFTER GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL
BRITAIN LISTED IN UNITED STATES
ARMY NEW DESIGN TO THE EIGHTY
SECOND AIRBORNE DIVISION
SPECIALIZING IN PARACHUTE
ASSAULT OPERATIONS. MEAN HE
JUMPED OUT OF A WHOLE LOT OF
PLANES
EIGHTY FIVE TO BE EXACT.
AFTER SERVING OUR NATION BRETT
FOUND WHAT HE BELIEVED BE HIS
TRUE CALLING LAW ENFORCEMENT.
HE GRADUATED FROM THE ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX ANNUAL POLICE
ACADEMY IN OFFICIALLY BEGAN HIS
CAREER WITH SENEGAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT AS A PATROL OFFICER.
IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE.
RIGHT CLIMB THROUGH THE RANKS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF VISUALLY
BECOMING A DETECTIVE WITH THE
HOMICIDE UNIT.
ALONGSIDE HIS PARTNER JC SMITH
HE WORKED TO SOLVE NUMEROUS
CRIME CRIMINAL CASES SEVERAL OF
WHICH WERE CONSIDERED TO BE
EXTREMELY HIGH PROFILE.
BUT NO MATTER THE CASE A THE
LEVEL OF ITS PROFILE BRETT LOVED
HIS JOB. AND HE SERVED OUR GREAT
CITY WITH DISTINCTION.
AFTER SERVING TWENTY FIVE YEARS
OF THE SENEGALESE DEPARTMENT
BRETT WENT ON TO JOIN THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN TWENTY FIFTEEN TO
CONTINUE HIS SERVICE TO OUR
COMMUNITY. AS DISTRICT ATTORNEY
INVESTIGATOR.
IN JULY TWENTY SEVENTEEN BRAT
WAS DIAGNOSED WITH NGO SARCOMA A
RARE FORM OF CANCER FOUND IN THE
BLOOD VESSELS OF THE HEART.
DESPITE THAT DIAGNOSIS RIGHT
CONTINUE TO FIGHT INTO LIVE
LIFE.
BECAUSE OF THIS THAT BRETT'S
FAMILY AND FRIENDS ADOPTED A
MOTTO IN A HASHTAG VERY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. BRETT STRONG WHICH
AFFIRMED THAT NO ONE FIGHTS.
ALONE.
INDEED BRETT WAS STRONG EVEN
WHEN BUT VALIANTLY BATTLING
CANCER BRETT WAS ABLE TO EARNED
HIS BACHELOR'S OF SCIENCE DEGREE
IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
GRADUATED* LAUDE FROM
NATIONAL UNIVERSITY.
WE GOT ITALY ON MARCH SIXTH A
TWENTY EIGHTEEN JUST TWO DAYS
AFTER A VERY SPECIAL BRETT
STRONG GATHERING WITH HIS FAMILY
AND CLOSE FRIENDS. BRETT PASSED
AWAY.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
DANIELLE. HIS SON MATT.
SISTER BETSY AND HIS LONGTIME
PARTNER JC.
BUT WILL ALWAYS BE REMEMBERED
FOR HIS INFECTIOUS LAUGHTER AND
HIS TRADEMARK GIGGLE AS WELL AS
HIS BIG HEART.
WHICH WAS NOT ONLY DEMONSTRATED
IN HIS QUALITY TIME WITH HIS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS BUT ALSO
EVERY SINGLE DAY BUT HE WORE HIS
BADGE AND WENT OUT TO PROTECT.
SERVE OUR COMMUNITY.
UNDOUBTEDLY.
UNDOUBTEDLY BRETT LEFT THIS
WORLD A BETTER PLACE THAN HE
FOUND IT. MASK AGAIN MY
COLLEAGUES TO JOIN TODAY IN HIS
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA.
MISTER KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY.
TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF DIANNE
LINDBERGH.
THE SENATE IS A RESIDENT ONE
FABRIC TWENTY EIGHTH PASSED AWAY
PEACEFULLY AFTER HER BRAVE.
BATTLE WITH CANCER AT HOME
ALONGSIDE HER LOVING WIFE JANICE
MORGAN.
I MET DIANE ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS.
WHEN SHE WAS WORKING FOR THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE AND
VOLUNTEERING HER TIME FOR THE
COMMUNITY. A IN PARTICULAR WHEN
SHE WAS WORKING AT THE SOUTH
SIDE COMMUNITY CENTER IN THE
COUNCIL DISTRICT.
THESE REPRESENT.
I DIANE'S VISION OF A CAREER A
COMMUNITY SERVICE WAS
DEMONSTRATED EARLY IN HER LIFE.
WHEN SHE SERVED AS A VOLUNTEER
JUNIOR RECREATIONAL LEADER ALMA
PARK IN SAN JOSE. AND OTHER
FACILITIES IN OUR COMMUNITY.
SHE WENT ON TO GRADUATE.
FROM OUR HOME UNIVERSITIES A
STATE UNIVERSITY.
AND THEN WENT ON TO HAVE A GREAT
CAREER WITH THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE.
AS CITY STAFF PLAN FOCUS ON
NUTRITION AND SERVICES FOR OLDER
ADULTS AT THE SOUTH SIDE SENIOR
CENTER. AND THE GARDENER
COMMUNITY CENTER.
SHE COMPLETED HER NOTABLE CAREER
AS A COMMUNITY SERVICE
SUPERVISOR WHILE SERVING AS A
DIRECTOR AT THE CENTER OF THE
OFFICE OF AGING. UNTIL HER
RETIREMENT.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN ADJOURNING IN
THE MEMORY OF DIANNE LINDBERGH.
GIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMANY
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ARE RISE TO JOIN IN MEMORY OF
POMONA POLICE OFFICER GREGORY
BECAUSE CS.
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY IS GRIEVING
AFTER THE LOSS OF OFFICER TO SEE
IF WHO WAS KILLED IN THE LINE OF
DUTY ON FRIDAY MARCH NINTH.
WE WERE REMINDED SUNDAY NIGHT
DURING A VIGIL OF HIS DEVOTION
OF FAMILY AND SERVICE.
HERE'S REMEMBERED AS BELOVED
OFFICER WITH THE POMONA POLICE
DEPARTMENT. DEDICATED FATHER
HUSBAND AND LOYAL FRIEND.
GREGORY ROSE TO THE RANKS AND
FULFILLED HIS LIFELONG DREAM OF
BEING A POLICE OFFICER.
AS THE FATHER OF A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
I KNOW HOW GRATEFUL WE ALL ARE
FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS TO PROTECT
US BEFORE THEMSELVES.
OFFICER BECAUSE HE HAS MADE THE
ULTIMATE SACRIFICE FIRST
COMMUNITY AND LOVED ONES HE IS A
HERO AND WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED
BY MANY.
POMONA POLICE CHIEF OLIVERI
REMINDED US ALL THAT GREAT GREEN
LEFTIST FOUND ME AT HOME TO
PROTECT ALL OF US.
I THANK HIM FOR HIS SERVICE.
MEMBERS THAT THIS INCIDENT
REMIND US OF ALL THE SACRIFICES
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS MAKE
EVERYDAY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN HONORING OFF
SICK TO SEE US AND THE MEN AND
WOMEN OF THE POMONA POLICE
DEPARTMENT BAR DURING IN HIS
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ SAID MR
HOLDEN ON THIS IN GERMANY
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN AND.
SOLIDARITY WITH OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM POMONA TASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF OFFICER
GREGORY'S CONSIDERS
WHO PASSED AWAY AT AGE THIRTY.
OSOCOZY IS LIFE WAS TRAGICALLY
CUT SHORT LATE LAST FRIDAY
AFTERNOON.
DURING THAT FRIDAY SHIFT WHOSE
LAST FILL TRAINING SHIFT A
RECKLESS DRIVER LET OFFICES ON A
PURSUIT THAT ENDED WITH A CRASH.
ADVOCACY IS DIRECTLY FOLLOWED
THE DRIVER INTO POMONA APARTMENT
COMPLEX WHERE THE MAN BARRICADED
HIMSELF.
SHOT AT POLICE OFFICERS FAIRLY
STRIKING CONSIDERS AND A SECOND
OFFICER WHO TRIED TO RESCUE IN.
ADVOCACY IS WAS DESCRIBED BY HIS
COLLEAGUES AS A GENTLE GIANT A
HARD WORKER WHO LOVE TO JOKE
AROUND WITH AND MOTIVATE HIS CO
WORKERS.
HE WAS A LOCAL PRODUCT IN A
BRAVE MAN WHO IS RESPECTED IN
THE COMMUNITY FOR HIS WORK ETHIC
AND PASSION TOWARDS BECOMING AN
OFFICER.
MAY WE MOURN HIS LOSS AND HONOR
THOSE WHO CARRY THE MEMORY AND
TOLL. OF OFFICER KASEY IS
ULTIMATE SACRIFICE.
ELECTED MAKE OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
POMONA AND AGAIN JOIN IN.
ASKING THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES THE DESK
TO BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
OUR REQUEST WOULD YOUR MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
FRIDAY MARCH SIXTEENTH NO FLOOR
SESSION NO CHECK IN SESSION.
MONDAY MARCH NINETEEN FLOOR
SESSION AT ONE PM.
RECESS WILL FOLLOW FLOOR SESSION
AND THEN FLOOR SESSION WILL
RECONVENE AT THREE THIRTY PM.
FOR THE STATE OF THE JUDICIARY
ADDRESS.
AT FOUR PM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
THE PASS RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I AM READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN MISTER
HOLDEN MOVES.
AND MISTER MULLIN SECONDS.
MISTER BERMAN IS STILL ON THE
FLOOR MISTER BERMAN SECONDS.
AT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED.
UNTIL MONDAY MARCH NINETEENTH AT
ONE PM IN THE FORM CALL IS
LIFTED